how are you Rex going on rich I'm
sitting here licking my wounds today
well and and you guys are discounting
yes we can't what we can't win it now in
November one day well we do can Alabama
I know we're a football school now but
come on nice man I love you tweet I got
to read it I got it right here here's
the tweet that when I saw it I'm like
I'm like I got to reach out to Rex to
get him on the show tomorrow here's a
tweet Xion Williamson is earl campbell
with double order of charles barkley a
large side of mario lemieux and a small
Rickey Henderson together which plague
which which play caused you to reach for
your your phone and tweet that one out
you know I don't know it was one way he
got a rebound at about 12 feet took off
down the floor dropped a little pass to
someone for a dunk and it reminded me of
watching Charles back in the day when he
was at awkward now
Zions in better shape than Charles lon
but he's weird like that
he's an oddity he's you know Charles is
my size 6 465 7-foot wingspan when he
stepped out on the floor with him and
when I talked to Charles side by side
once I thought when I stepped down on
the floor with him with our uniforms on
he may as well been seven feet tall
Howard begi play and that's like Zion
freakin long freaky athletic big eighty
pounds fast quick twist he he had guys
isolated a couple times out cop you know
big athletic quit guys was around them
and dunking it at the basket was where
you could he just another thing he's got
it he's tough over there he wanted to
beat us by a thousand last night they
almost did he and yet you know you speak
to evaluators and certainly coming in in
terms of star recruits Zions maybe not
the the the most valued recruit or
player that's on the team I mean you
take a look at the way that Barrett
played last night as well Rex that's
probably why people think that you could
just hand do
the the trophy right now yeah and don't
forget about Redis you know RJ uh no no
no RJ for a long time it's Stevie NASA's
godson Steve he's a good friend of mine
wrong growing Barretts RJ dad Owen
Barrett you could put our rolling
Barrett in any game and he's going to
get and he's capable getting 30 35
points he's a scorer Kings scorer
right-handed left-handed he just goes at
you and camera at us he sees that thing
like like he means it I mean it's water
they've got three I mean health
permitting free lottery picks maybe high
lottery pick
you've got to get through the season
it's a weird college season they're all
still teenagers 18 19 years old none of
them have really played any more
basketball than the others they're gonna
they're gonna lose a few games they got
to stay healthy
you saw what I mean Duke had a terrific
team last year so you know it's gonna
it's gonna be tough it's gonna be tough
for everybody
but it's gonna be tough of the teams
that play out to we're really good we
are really good all right Rex I'll give
you the floor on that on Kentucky
basketball even though they just got
smoked last night as you point out go
for you yeah
Tyler harrows the real deal Tyler here
oh sorry Calvin Johnson the real deal
read Travis transfer we're gonna be
really good PJ Washington didn't play
his best last night but as I was telling
somebody good players can make you look
that you know we looked awfully well
against transiently plays the Bahamas
and a couple exhibition but then you
play a real team and now we can kind of
figure out where we are and we'll have
to go back I know the cows team get
better all year long every I look for us
to be in the Final Four this year really
okay Rex so then where do you stand on
the subject of one-and-done players
because it seems like the we are now in
full one-and-done blossom bloom like
last night's game is a perfect example
of that in college basketball right now
where do you stand on that subject to
this place I think you should be able to
go right out of high school I don't
think that I think you should ever be
able to enter to the grass right now
school that's what you want to do
college isn't for everybody but you
league has put this new thing in where
they can create kids 125 grand some kids
will do that
my my position on that is that's a big
risk if you're one of the top if you're
a McDonald's kid projected to be in the
lottery in a year but you have to go to
college for a year order you have to go
to the G League going to the G Li and
plan against grown man who played four
years of college most of them we're
going out every night all of that
they're not going to nobody's gonna
babysit you in the G League for 125 and
then you're gonna get exposed unless
you're really good and really mature now
instead of being a lottery pick or
whatever after your first year in
college you played against G League
competition and now you've got your
you've got no more juice
you know you played you've been exposed
you might not even get drafted now so
it's a heck of a risk to take I really
salute feel like you ought to be able to
go right out of high school and just
like every other sport except football
you can get killed in that game if
you're not physically mature no that's
true that is a date uuuuuhhh the the
biggest fallacy I'm here every year I
guess to come full circle with the poll
question that we just had at the top
here is that Alabama would be able to
beat the the Giants of the Raiders no I
no way no chance I mean nobody said that
to me the other day to about Duke or
Kentucky being able to beat no it was
about Alabama I said you're out of your
mind
no way come on so would would Duke as
currently constituted though give a game
to the current Cleveland Cavaliers with
with Kevin Love out right now Rex no no
yeah I mean come on come on man you know
rich they're gonna get out there and
play against wrong man 2530 years old
yeah they've been saved in they played
so much more basketball
you go out it no they couldn't do it
they couldn't do it I'd love to agree
with you
just even though I just said it would
never have in the MBA actually why I
mean the NFL I just went there with the
NBA but Zion just looks like such a
grown-ass man racks it snow though he is
and again RJ has you know his game is
like he's grown I really you could put
RJ Anna on an NBA team right now and you
know in another month he did be getting
twenty a game in the NBA I think I mean
he's a he's a natural-born scorer
so was did you ever play with somebody
you think would have been one and done
if the one in Dunn era was something
potentially real when you were there in
Kentucky
come in and done it back you know in my
day I certainly could have done one year
out of her right out of high school I
didn't weigh 165 pounds and not much
more than that after my freshman here
Derek : could have done it back in the
day there are guys I played with
physically they could do remember
islands and to do it but by and large
you know it's very cost and we get those
few that come through that can do it
it's a very it's a risk to try to leave
and go from high school yeah maturity
wise as much as anything else
but it's very tough and it's very tough
to go in and succeed and do it Kobe was
terrible in the first game and terrible
Kevin Garnett was terrible your main
O'Neil was terrible they couldn't even
put them on the floor cuz they can have
a position and nobody could guard nobody
to guard so you've got to be really good
then they stayed with it and picked it
up if you're not good like they are
you'll just be washed out in no time so
it's a gamble so coach Calipari said
after the game that they got outcoached
outplayed how do you think he handles
this knowing one would think that he
just saw potentially the best
competition that stands in the way of of
a team that that that you described and
I'm sure Calipari to his core feels is
good enough to win a national
championship this year
my my my gut is his hair's on fire today
hey and it will stay on fire until we
play those guys again
just sort of how expired
you know I could tell I go watch this
practice most every day here you know he
really had this game circle and but you
know obviously you want to win but you
want to find out where you are and we
found out who we are compared to those
guys right now and I know Cal Hall of
Fame kind of guy or call same guy this
is going to stick with it
it's going to stick with this staff a
Kenny Payne Joel justice Tony Party
those guys they'll get back to work and
we'll start grinding again but that's
how you have to look at it I love it I
love it because so many people think
that they you know the intensity doesn't
really ratchet up until conference play
or no tournament play but you're saying
that this one despite it being on
election night right Tuesday and in in
November maybe not everybody saw it
because there was split screens going
down that that's gonna leave a mark
on Kentucky basketball for a long time
until they get to play each other well I
you know it'll it'll sting for a little
bit but again I'm just happy we're
talking about it it's fun to talk
basketball being a football school great
job Rex man I love following you on
Twitter too at Rex underscore records
yeah thanks for calling in a chat with
you down the line well throughout the
season I'd love to you got Rex thanks
for the call it's Rex Chapman the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience